a shock Paswan is bartlett's UK chief
executive and the man who launched the
scheme today so I shall cut younger
people are more educated people and most
vulnerable why is that is it because
they've got more gadgets in actually I
was quite fascinated with the results
myself and I think what it is about is
that the more you get digitally active
the less you know you become much more
blase about it right and the less kind
of precautions you take and that's what
this is really about this is about
saying hey the bad guys out there
together we can fight to beat them so
older customers for more digitally savvy
not necessarily their digitally the use
of digital is much more with youngsters
but there also are less careful about
how they use digital right now what do
you you you're spending 10 million fans
on this what are you where's that money
gonna go so the whole idea is to raise a
bunch of awareness the first thing is
you take a quiz to understand how you
know how you are on the safety index so
this week I tried it I was hopeless at
it proves the point right of the
research and then the question is just
making you aware the interesting thing
is it's actually quite simple I mean if
you just take three or four simple steps
right you can get much more safe make
sure your passwords are not your first
name with your birthdate and stuff like
that make sure you don't share your
passwords don't allow somebody else to
take away your computer really really
pretty simple stuff which can help all
of us win now you said you want
businesses and the public and the police
to all work together to combat cyber
fraud I mean how much information to the
bank's actually share on cyber fraud
right now well we work very closely with
the police on the mat we're working
closely under things like the BBA but
the banks get together to tackle fraud
fraud is a big issue and all of us need
to get together to defeat the bad guys
what about this issue the police I mean
are they doing enough do you think so
you know a lot of this also ian is about
people who get defrauded the stigma of
actually saying I got defrauded it's
it's fantastic the research also shows
that when people get defrauded they
still don't change most of them still
don't change their habits right and
therefore they don't complain but we've
had a very very good relationship with
the police and the bank
kind of coming together to kind of fight
this issue now looking at the economy
more widely at the moment we've heard a
lot of talk about migration today we've
heard about macron wanting to make
France more competitive for a big
international bank like Barclays do you
worry about talent draining away so yeah
we are a British bank we've been here
for three hundred twenty six years we
hope to be here for the next hundred 26
years
Britain has seen a lot we've seen it
with it we will continue to go with it
now we do have about 3,000 European
Nationals in our network in our branches
on our trading floors and obviously we
are very committed to making sure that
they feel secure and they feel they can
have good jobs and lives in the UK and
in financial services it's only about
people right and therefore our ability
to get the best in the brightest to make
sure that financial services stays on
the cutting edge is really important
London has been a financial capital of
the world for a long period of time it
would be a shame if we lost that and
very briefly what's the mood like in
Barca's at the moment more generally
that you know Sunday Times yesterday
saying the CEO Jess Daley to another two
strikes one more and he's out I mean
what's the mood like internally right
now in its focus on the customer and the
client if you focus on the customer and
the client everything else will fall
into place right you can't get your ball
off your eye off the ball customer
client get it right by them all right
I'm sure that's one we've got to leave
it there thanks very much for joining me
good to see